taking another look at a general
election contest heading in towards uh
november of course we're looking at the
clark county district attorney race and
tim treffinger is here running for
district attorney as a republican tim it
is good to see you sir thank you it's a
pleasure to be here let's just get into
why you're running in the first place
against steve wolson who's been in
wolfson has been an incumbent for a long
time as you know
why jump into the race well part of it's
i believe in balance and i believe in
equality on both sides and the da's race
historically at least for the past
couple of cycles have just been a
democratic primary and when i saw that
no one was going to jump in on the
conservative side i felt it was
important to have those voices
recognized and that's why i'm in this
race what is it about mr wolfson's
performance as
as prosecutor in clark county that
concerns you that you think you would do
differently if you were elected into
office sure i think mainly it comes down
to a matter of leadership i mean he is
not going into court and prosecuting
cases he has taken a very administrative
role and i think because of that
disconnect between him and his deputies
not all of his policies are being
enforced they're not being done
consistently
there's a lot of great attorneys in that
office there's just a lack of leadership
and involvement in day-to-day running in
the court system you have said that you
will if you're elected pick up a case
from time to time to prosecute if you're
elected as a district attorney
what cases would you prosecute whatever
cases the office needed help with i
don't plan on just taking the high end
cases i think you need to pick up and
support your deputies even if you're
second chairing some cases anything to
do to support the office that way you're
plugged in with your deputies you know
what's going on day to day coming out of
your office maybe just a little more
specifically just to backtrack a little
bit of of you talk about the lack of
leadership at the district attorney's
office how has that manifested itself in
your point of view
in prosecutions in criminal justice and
just how the wheels of of the
prosecutor's office are moving sure it's
it's a matter of consistency i think
more than anything else you should be
able to walk into a courtroom similar
people facing similar charges and kind
of know what to expect but especially
recently and there's been many stories
about people who they believe should
have been charged maybe weren't because
they were financially involved or
friends of steve's or whoever
it needs to be consistent no matter who
you are whether you're a citizen a judge
a cop all the laws need to be enforced
efficiently and equally and that's just
not happening now you're making uh
you're addressing something that ozzy
fumo who ran against steve in the in the
democratic primary mentioned as well
sort of an allegation of favoritism
something that steve himself has
adamantly denied do you believe that the
prosecutor's office place favorites
i believe they shouldn't i haven't seen
enough evidence to firmly point a finger
and say he's playing favorites what i
can say is it's not happening consistent
consistently and whatever the reason for
that is i think it's inappropriate
another issue you've brought up is
family court and
corruption in family court what are some
examples that you think are happening
here in clark county well we have a lot
of issues in family court there's a lot
of inconsistency there too depending on
what department you're walking into it's
unclear how the law is going to be
applied we have contempt charges coming
up where people are not afforded the
right to counsel and are thrown in jail
for a period of time there's a lot of
different things there that i think can
either be handled better and if there
are people playing favorites or doing
corrupt things in family court that
should be investigated and that should
be prosecuted perhaps one thing maybe
viewers at home should note is you know
they may not know who you are tell me
about your background in law and your
experience in prosecution sure i came
out of law school from university of new
hampshire graduated with the jd and llm
in international criminal law and social
justice
came out to nevada out to virginia city
of all places story county where i spent
about a year
finishing my externship from there i
went into the nevada attorney general's
office where i prosecuted sex crimes
domestic violence crimes against women
for three counties
and then went into private practice and
i've been there ever since right now i
focus mainly on criminal defense and
family law
part of your past is your own experience
with with criminal prosecution you
entered a plea deal on heroin charges
back in 2015. maybe explain to the to
the viewers what happened back then and
maybe how that experience has
changed
you and maybe changed your your practice
and what you how you perceive the
justice system sure when i came out of
law school i expected to be a prosecutor
my entire career so being on the other
side of that table was certainly a
surreal experience
i went through the diversion program an
ex of mine developed a drug issue i was
trying to get her clean unfortunately in
the midst of trying to get her clean she
was selling drugs out of the house while
i wasn't home
police come and raid the house i end up
in the system myself i did i did do a
plea agreement for a possession charge i
went through the diversion program which
i am a huge proponent of that gives
people second chances who have never
been in trouble before or first-time
offenders
had my case dismissed but i think it
gives me an appreciation of both sides
of the table not only have i been a
prosecutor and a criminal defense
attorney i've been a defendant i
understand what that process is like i
understand the benefits of those
programs and giving people certain
people chances because probation in my
opinion isn't hard if you follow the
rules and i think everybody deserves a
second chance but you know if you can't
work within that system the prison is
always there for you so i am hard on
crime i just believe in diversion
programs
you so you mentioned how the your
experience uh with these charges you
learned that side of the diversion
program and probation and so forth were
there other things that you learned
about the prosecution standpoint that
you think maybe could be brought to
clark county absolutely i think my case
in particular
i was made an example of because i was a
prosecutor in that county
i think that most other people in my
situation would have been offered a
lighter deal than what i had to go
through and i think that just shows
favoritism isn't appropriate at any
level everybody should be treated the
same a police officer who's prosecuted
for domestic violence for example
shouldn't face harsher penalties than
the person on the street everybody
should be treated equally
you talked about the diversion programs
and so forth uh there's some specialty
courts in in clark county we've got the
drug courts veterans courts for example
should those continue do you think those
are successes yes veterans court in
particular i think is incredibly
important those people go through things
and experience trauma that most of us
everyday people have never been in the
military would never understand i think
that that court in particular is very
important drug court is incredibly
important drugs are wreaking havoc on
this county it's part of the reason that
our crime rate is so high and trying to
get people clean so that they don't keep
going back through the system over and
over again is an incredibly important
thing i think those programs could be
expanded without going too much into
taxpayer pockets and i believe that
everybody should have access to those
programs right now the da's office is
kind of gatekeeping everyone should be
able to apply it shouldn't be which
prosecutor you get decides what program
you can go into
another issue in nevada for years has
been the issue of the death penalty uh
the incumbent mr wolfson says he kind of
likes to have it out there just in case
essentially that
that's kind of why it's there
um
what's your stance on the death penalty
i am pro-death penalty but i believe
it's a specific tool for a specific
purpose it's for the worst of the worst
cases i don't think anyone here
or at least most people wouldn't argue
that the the october festival shooter
was not enough had he survived that
would have been an appropriate death
penalty case uh i don't believe it's for
every case i do believe it needs to be
you know instituted in an even and equal
manner and only for the worst of the
worst cases but i am pro-death penalty
that on that issue the issue of of the
specialty courts the issue of you know
other aspects family courts and so forth
a lot of the things you're describing
don't sound too dissimilar from the way
things are now just help me understand
the difference between you and your
opponent when people go into the ballot
box how are you different how would your
uh running the da's office be different
than mr wolfson i'm going to bring
equality and consistency if you if
you're able to apply for a specialty
corps program it shouldn't matter what
prosecutor in front of like i said that
should be available to everybody let the
judges decide who they allow into those
programs consistency of charging i'm
going to make sure the charges are
brought where it's appropriated whether
it's favoritism or just a negligence
whatever you want to call it because of
these charging decisions that type of
stuff is going to stop i'm also not for
decriminalizing shoplifting and things
that are causing damage to our small
businesses i believe i have a much
tougher stance on crime than steve does
and while we do agree on certain things
like the death penalty i still don't
agree with how consistently he applies
the death penalty he does use it in
limited cases but i don't always agree
that they're the correct cases or that
it's applied evenly
it's very interesting race and tim it's
good for you to come around and talk
with us about your entrance in as a
republican for the clark county district
attorney's office appreciate the time
thank you for having me running for
clark county district attorney